let's return to the UN Security Council
in New York the minister for foreign
affairs from Russia Sergey lavrov
speaking I think this very timely
because this is precisely this term
impunity reflects what has been going on
in that country since 2014 the national
radical forces
opens and neo-nazis came to power then
as a result of an armed coup with direct
support of Western countries and right
after that they took the path of
lawlessness and totally ignoring main
rights and freedoms the right to life
right of expression right of access to
information
uh right of conscience the right to use
is native language and uh to date the
crimes on the maidan in February 2014
remain unpunished those who perpetrated
the horrific tragedy in Odessa on the
2nd of May of 2014 have not been found
or punished at the time at the house of
labor unions dozens were burned alive
and died in the same categories of
political murders of Alessia Busan
public Sherman and other public figures
and journalists in spite of that there's
an attempt today to impose on us a
completely different narrative about
Russian aggression as the origin of uh
this ignores the fact that for over
eight years the Ukrainian Army and
fighters from the Nationalist formations
killed and continued to kill
inhabitants of dunbas with impunity
simply because they refused to recognize
the result of the coup de time they
decided to uphold their rights which
were guaranteed by the Ukrainian
Constitution including the right to
freely use Russian their mother tongue
foreign
authorities they declared all those who
don't agree there as terrorists and for
eight years the key of regime has been
conducted has been conducting a military
operation against a peaceful civilians
and by the way
in Ukraine for many years now
total mobilization of all adult uh uh
population including women is being
conducted in order to recruit them into
the ranks of nationalist battalions and
the Armed Forces
Now by cynically declaring its
commitment to the Minsk agreements in
Kiev authorities overtly sabotaged their
implementation
Financial transport blockade on a bus
people were denied their pensions their
subsidies their access to education they
they were
they would deny their basic civil rights
including those that were guaranteed by
the uh International pacts of 1966.
then Mr zelensky having been tired of
pretending being
stated that
this could it was not impossible to
implement the Minsk agreement in fact Mr
poroshenko just a couple months ago
proudly stated that the Minsk agreements
which he signed neither him nor no one
else in the Ukraine had any intention of
implementing these that these agreements
were simply needed to win time in order
to obtain weapons from the West to uh
for the war against Russia
the secretary of the National Security
and defense counsel Mr Danielle have
said something very similar of course
the key of regime owes its impunity to
its Western sponsors first of all
Germany and France but also the United
States instead of pushing the key of
authorities to implement them into
agreement Berlin and Paris and
Washington cynically ignored the growing
threats of kiev2 resolve the problem of
dumbass by force so God Plan B over the
past few years the key of regime has
conducted a frontal assault on the
Russian language it brazenly trampled on
the rights of Russian and
russian-speaking people in Ukraine the
scandalous language laws were enacted on
education in 2016 on ensuring the role
of Ukrainian language as a state
language in 2019. on the comprehensive
General secondary education in 2020 on
native peoples of Ukraine in 2021. all
these laws are aimed at
ousting the Russian language in essence
it's complete bam at the same time laws
were adopted that promoted the theory
and practice of Nazism
intimid recommendations of the Venetian
Commission of the Council of Europe and
the office of the High Commissioner of
Human Rights the osce High Commissioner
on minorities on amending the language
legislation were simply ignored by Keith
and these multilateral structures at the
same time
didn't find the courage or they were not
allowed to convince the key of
authorities to fulfill their obligations
they undertook in the area of Human
Rights the Ministry of Education
um of Ukraine has excluded Russian and
Russian
literature from the school curriculum uh
books are being destroyed just as in
Nazi Germany
um and ethnic Russians are being subject
to intolerance and today the officials
from Ukraine have no no longer even
tried to hide their anti-russian
feelings calling on the killing of
Russians just a few examples Mr of
rublevsky the Ukrainian ambassador to
Kazakhstan who's now in Kiev just a
month ago declared in an interview and I
quote we're trying to kill the Russians
as much as many Russians as possible the
more we kill today the fewer
our children will need to kill and of
course did anyone notice this quote just
earlier this uh April the mayor of nipro
filatov said something similar the time
of cold blooded Fury has come now we
have a full moral right to calmly and
with a clear mind to kill these
non-humans around the world for as long
as possible and as many as possible end
of quote on the 13th of September of
this year just recently Mr danilov
towns where the Ukrainian Armed Forces
enter people will undergo euchronization
without taking into account their views
this will apply not only to Russians but
representatives of other nationalities
if you want to study any other language
such as Romanian polish
please go ahead but not just to be
financed by our estate you can do it at
your own expense you can improve your
educational level at your own expense
end of quote is there any need to say
that all these russophobic statements
have become have remained unpunished and
we're not even talking about rusevo
we'll be here
individual spoke about representatives
of other ethnic groups that live in
Ukraine and of course the ultimate was
the interview with
zelensky on the 5th of August
suggested to everyone who feels that
they're rushing for the good of their
children and grandchildren to get the
hell out and to go to Russia and I think
the the decisions that have been adopted
by a whole range of uh regions of
Ukraine about conducting referendums the
result of uh of his uh advice and under
the guise of uh combating Russian
aggression and separatism Ukraine is
strengthening its persecution of
dissidents and March ban on the activity
of 11 political parties under the
pretext of their links to Russia uh
opposition Russian language television
channels have been closed for any
attempt to provide an alternative view
to the official view
journalists are persecuted Madame
bearish Naya a well-known public
official who has often spoken at the U.N
and the OBC is in the prisons of the
security services we have no doubt that
Ukraine has become a complete completely
totalitarian nazi-like state where
the Norms of international humanitarian
Lord trampled on there's no surprise
that the armed forces and the national
battalions are using the tactic of
terrorists using using these civilians
as human shield and here what's
particularly cynical is the position of
states that are pumping Ukraine full of
weapons and training uh their soldiers
the goal is obvious they they're clearly
stating it to drag out the fighting as
long as possible in spite of the victims
and destruction in order to wear down
and weaken Russia that
policy uh means the direct involvement
of the West and the conflict and makes
them a party into the conflict the
intention of fomenting by this of this
conflict by the collective West the West
remains
unpunished of course you won't punish
yourselves sir we have no illusions that
today the Armed Forces of Russia are
being and the militias of lugansk and
Donetsk are being opposed not only by
the Neo-Nazi formations of the Kiev
regime but the military machine of the
collective West
and in real time the regime of real time
using using modern systems of weapons uh
ships satellites drones NATO is
providing into the uh Ukrainian armed
forces and stating that
convincing them that Russia should be
defeated on the field of battle the
official representatives of the European
Union have stated this and Russia should
be punished by having any sovereignty
strip from it this is an even latent
racism but overt right
against the backdrop of mass shelling of
towns and cities of dunbas Mr zielinski
is Overjoyed at the effectiveness of
Western weapons here's a quote at last
we feel how powerfully Western artillery
has begun to operate the weapons that
we've received from our Western Partners
it's accuracy is exactly what we need
cynically cynically stated
um
same time no there were no military or
strategic targets located in the towns
that were shelled only peaceful citizens
of them
are suffering since the end of July the
armed forces are lobbing mortar rounds
to the center of Donetsk and his
environs that are banned they're lobbing
banned anti-personnel rounds is called
Loeber blade they're this
this violates a convention in 1997 on
the banana personal mines ratified by
Ukraine as well as the second protocol
of the Geneva Convention on the
Conventional Weapons such outrages are
remain unpunished because the United
States and their allies were the
connivance of international human rights
institutes have been covering up the the
crimes of the cave regime based on the
policy of Zealand he might be a bastard
Inconvenient Truth that darkens the
image of Ukraine as the victim of
Russian aggression is carefully hushed
up and sometimes deleted even Western
human rights organization Amnesty
International which is difficult to
accuse of sympathies to Russia has been
severely criticized and and called an
agent of the creme simply because in its
report it's confirmed facts about the
fact that Kim places heavy weapons at
civilian facilities the
um
the criminal shelling of the zaporovsky
nuclear power plant remain unpunished
even though from the first of September
representatives of the iae have been
present there and it's very it's not
very difficult to establish who's guilty
for the shelling and I just want to
recall that the visit of the iaea
mission
was artificially delayed even though
already on the 3rd of June all details
were agreed and the mission could have
could have gone to the power plant
already and then
it was a very unpleasant situation
Department Security of the U.N refused
to give authorization the specific
itinerary
this is not a very honest uh honest
actions that simply delayed the visit to
the zapposia power plan by two months
even by three months
about the fate of Russian uh soldiers
who uh were taking the prisoners there
are very many examples uh of uh
um torture including violation of
international humanitarian law I'm sure
that all those who are interested in
what actually happened saw a video of uh
the torture atrocities by a Ukrainian
neo-nazis against Russian soldiers who
were thrown into the ground with their
hands tied and were shot to the in the
head
did anyone here comment on this uh the
crime at all we have many many witness
witness Witnesses of these criminal
activities by the cave regime that have
been happening since 2014. Russian law
enforcement bodies cooperating with
their colleagues
republics are investigating these
thoroughly over 220 individuals there
have been considered have been found to
be complicit including the high command
of the Ukrainian Armed Forces uh command
commanders of units who were shelled who
shelled the civilian population also
there were cases against the mercenaries
from citizens of UK Canada United States
Netherlands Etc I can assure you that
all perpetrators dependently of their
nationality will be held accountable I
also want to draw your attention to the
following
Russian and Ukrainian negotiators at the
end of March practically
reach an agreement
on the parameters of us an agreement
proposed by KIA just uh a couple days
later the tragedy and bucha occurred the
fact that it was staged uh leaves no
doubt in anyone's mind and I want to
draw your attention
Western colleagues right after that
staged event immediately cried outrage
and introduced a new package of
sanctions a spuriously accusing us of
killing uh innocent civilians since then
when that propaganda
operation was conducted no one has
mentioned butcher other than us and once
again in the presence of the secretary
generals and ministers I would address
you
please demand the Ukrainian authorities
to make a simple step take a simple
steps
to publish information about those
individuals whose body bodies were shown
in bucha I've been asking this for the
past month Secretary General
please use your Authority for this
useful to to get to the bottom of this
episode and of course we also noticed
the increased activity of international
Justice with regard to Ukraine there's
supposedly efforts to investigate the
crimes committed in Ukraine that are
that are ascribed to Russian authorities
all this is simply
a propaganda operation I just wanted to
recall that neither the uh coup d'etat
2014 or the or the tragedy in Odessa or
the shelling of donuts
any other crimes
have let any reaction
from the international criminal court
and by the way this international
criminal court
there were some 3 000 3 000 the
references sent to the international
criminal court against criminals crimes
committed against the inhabitants of ICC
there has been no reaction and it seems
that the ICC has now received
instructions to step up its activity we
have no confidence in the work of this
body
past States eight months we were waiting
for uh for uh steps to be taken against
impunity in Ukraine and we don't expect
anything more from this institution or a
whole range of other International
institutions everything I've said today
simply confirms that the decision to
conduct the special military operation
was inevitable we have said this more
than once we've provided a huge a number
of facts which show how
Ukraine prepared to play the role of
anti-russia is the staging ground to
create threatens against Russian
security and I can assure you that we
will never accept this thank you very
much